-Donald Trump is sharpening
his attacks against one
of his likely opponents
for the GOP nomination,
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis,
even as prosecutors
in New York indicate
that they are closer than ever
to indicting Trump
and members
of a Georgia grand jury
say their investigation
of Trump could be massive.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Trump and DeSantis have both
been hitting the campaign trail,
even though DeSantis has not
officially announced
that he's running yet.
But I mean,
you can tell he's running.
For one thing,
he seems to be wearing suits
that actually fit him, now,
instead of whatever the hell's
going on here.
[ Laughter ]
He looks like he's cheating
in a chess tournament.
[ Laughter ]
Look, I get it.
We've all been there.
You got a formal event,
you forget to buy a suit,
you rifle through your closet
at the last minute
and you find an old jacket
that doesn't fit anymore
and you end up looking like
a cat standing on its hind legs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Been there.
But DeSantis gearing up
for a run
also means he's attracted
the bloodshot Eye of Sauron,
[ Laughter ]
his main rival, Donald Trump,
who's been attacking DeSantis
on the campaign trail
and elsewhere.
In fact, Trump posted a pretty
remarkable video this week,
where he basically said
DeSantis was a failure
and the only reason
people like Florida
is because it's sunny there.
-For those of you
that didn't notice,
Florida was doing great long
before Ron DeSanctis got there.
[ Laughter ]
People are fleeing from New York
to Florida, and other places,
because of high taxes
and out of control crime.
It's really bad.
[ Laughter ]
Not because of the governor --
thank you, Mr. President,
for doing that --
but it's not
because of the governor.
Florida was doing fantastically.
You had a governor
named Rick Scott
who did a very good job.
Even Charlie Crist, a Democrat,
did a good job,
and he had very good numbers.
Sunshine and ocean
are very alluring.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-He sounds like a '60s radical,
explaining how two women
tricked him into joining a cult.
[ Laughter ]
[ Hippie voice ] Sunshine --
Sunshine and Ocean
were very alluring, man.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They told me my chakra's
aligned with theirs.
Next thing I knew,
my bank account was empty
and I was scrubbing
the maharishi's toilet.
[ Laughter ]
Still, man, I wouldn't trade
those times for anything.
I can't believe I'm saying this,
but I agree with Donald Trump.
Everything people like
about Florida
was in place
before Ron DeSantis.
He didn't do something magical
and suddenly convince people
they should move
to a warmer climate,
with beaches, golf courses,
theme parks, low taxes,
alligators on meth.
[ Laughter ]
If you think people living
in New York were saying,
"There's too many books
around here.
I want to go to a state
where there's less to read."
[ Laughter ]
But that video is such
a funny preview
of how Trump is going to tear
into all of his opponents.
He's already so mad at DeSantis,
he's praising
the former governor of Florida
Charlie Crist
[ Laughter ]
for doing a better job
than DeSantis.
Soon, Trump's going to be
so desperate to attack
his fellow Republicans,
he's going to endorse Obama.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] You know,
you know where else has sunshine
and ocean?
[ Laughter ]
Hawaii, home to my good friend
Barack Obama.
He was born there.
[ Laughter ]
He was born in Hawaii.
He has the birth certificate
and every-- I've seen it.
Beautiful birth certificate,
beautiful.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Gold leaf.
Held it in my hands.
Obama -- great man, great man.
Good at basketball.
He tried to teach poor Ron how
to shoot a three-pointer,
but Ron couldn't
raise his arms above his head.
So sad.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There's plenty more
to attack DeSantis on
because, as we've said before,
DeSantis is a weird guy,
but not as weird as Trump,
which is his main problem.
If you're a GOP voter who likes
weird, Trump's your guy.
But if you're normal --
if you like normal,
DeSantis is a little too weird.
He stands weird. He wears those
little, weird white boots.
[ Laughter ]
And now --
And now there's this new story
about his weird eating habits.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughter and ohhs ]
You ate pudding
with your fingers?
[ Laughter ]
That's not very DeSanitary.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You don't get to use
your fingers to eat pudding!
Here are the rules.
If you have pudding,
but you don't have a spoon,
then you
don't have pudding.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I've never thought
I'd say this about anyone,
but you should eat
more like Donald Trump.
[ Laughter ]
If you were in a plane next
to a guy
who was finger-blasting
Swiss Miss
[ Laughter ]
and asked to move
and the flight attendant said,
"The only open seat's next
to a dude eating KFC
with a knife and fork,"
you'd say, "Yeah, I guess,
in this case,
it beats the pudding dude."
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, there's a lot of material
for Trump to work with.
The only thing Trump hasn't
nailed down yet is the nickname.
I mean, I took Ron DeSanitary,
so that one's gone.
Sorry, dude.
[ Laughter ]
Trump's been calling him
Ron DeSanctimonious,
which doesn't exactly roll right
off the tongue,
so, then he shortens it.
He shortens DeSanctimonious
to make it easier to say.
-Florida was doing great long
before Ron DeSanctis got there.
[ Laughter ]
So just remember,
Florida was doing really well
long before Ron DeSanctis
got there.
-So, he shortened Sanctimonious
to Sanctis.
Makes total sense.
Smart people always shorten
long words like that.
[ Laughter ]
I remember when I got
my appendix looked at,
the doctor came in and said,
"Alright, looks like
we're going to have to do
a little appendy,
but don't worry.
[ Laughter ]
If anything happens,
we'll just shock you
with defibbies."
[ Laughter ]
I don't know
if he was a good doctor or not
because I didn't stay!
[ Laughter ]
So, Trump's decided to go
after DeSantis
before DeSantis even gets
in the race
and the most important
media organization
in the conservative movement,
Fox News, seems torn about it.
On the one hand, you have hosts,
like Brian Kilmeade,
who are cozying up to DeSantis,
but also seem impressed
by what they claim
is Trump's ability
to stay on message
after a run of bad press.
-He also is on a bit of a roll
since he went and visited
East Palestine,
stopped having lunch
with white supremacists,
and has got
a very disciplined message.
-I can't argue with the logic.
It's like saying,
"Hannibal Lecter
has been looking svelte
since he stopped eating people."
[ Laughter ]
Also, I love
that they're still waiting,
all these years later,
for a more disciplined
Donald Trump
to magically appear.
The man's 76. 76-year-olds
don't suddenly change,
unless they start taking Cialis.
[ Laughter ]
You know, after he started
taking Cialis,
Grandpa bought a fedora
and joined a band.
[ Laughter ]
But, of course, the big question
looming over the GOP primary is
whether Trump will get indicted.
He's facing
multiple investigations
in various jurisdictions,
at this point,
including state
and federal investigations
of his attempt to overturn
the 2020 election.
And I'm as tired as anyone
of hearing the probe
is intensifying
and the walls
are closing in on Trump.
It's like waiting around
for Sam and Diane
to finally kiss or, you know,
a better reference,
for people under 50.
[ Laughter ]
But in New York,
prosecutors are looking
into Trump's hush money payments
from 2016
and that case might be the
closest to an actual indictment.
-Donald Trump's former attorney
Michael Cohen
making his second
appearance tomorrow
before a New York grand jury.
He's the key witness in a case
investigating
a hush money payment
to adult film star
Stormy Daniels,
that payment made just days
before the 2016 election.
Prosecutors handling the case
are signaling
that a criminal indictment
for Trump could be coming soon.
-Man, it would be wild
if that's the thing
that brought Trump down.
The guy was impeached twice,
colluded with one
foreign country,
tried to extort another country
to interfere
in a presidential election
on his behalf,
and then fomented a violent coup
to stay in power,
but the thing that
could finally sink him
is paying off a porn star
not to tell everyone
about his weird penis,
when everyone already assumed
it looked weird.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Talk about throwing bad money
after good.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But Trump apparently has a new
lawyer to handle this case,
a guy whose real name is
Joe Tacopina.
I did not make that up.
I certainly would never use it
as a joke.
Like if someone asked me what
Stormy Daniels said about Trump,
I would never say,
"He's got a little Tacopina."
I wouldn't do that.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But Tacopina went
on MSNBC this week
to defend Trump's lie
that he didn't know
about the hush payment
with Stormy Daniels
and the interview
got contentious.
-One of the top trial attorneys
out of New York,
Joe Tacopina,
is defending Donald Trump
and our guests right now,
live on "The Beat," is...
Trump defense lawyer
Joe Tacopina.
[ Laughter ]
If all of what you say
is true...
-It is.
[ Laughter ]
-...then why was Trump hiding it
and lying about it at the time?
And I'll play that
for your response.
-Mm-hmm.
-He lied about it.
We all know that. Take a look.
-When you say he lied --
-Take a look.
-Let's see.
-Mr. President, did...
-Ari, that is --
if that's what you're going
to consider a lie --
A lie, to me,
Is something material,
under oath, in a procedural.
-I didn't say perjury.
I said a lie.
-Yeah, but that's not a lie.
That's called --
-That's not a lie?
-Here's why it's not a lie.
Could you put your paper --
-"Did you know about this?
-Put the paper down.
[ Laughter ]
Let me answer.
-Did you know about this?"
"No, I don't."
-We don't need that.
-[ As Tacopina ]
Hey, oh, what's with the paper?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey!
I thought we were friends.
Come on, we don't need that.
[ Laughter ]
You take out paper,
I got to take out scissors.
Next thing you know,
you're eating your pudding
with only two fingers.
[ Laughter and applause ]
As we mentioned, there are
other investigations of Trump,
including one in Georgia,
where prosecutors
are investigating
Trump's attempt to interfere
in the vote count
and are weighing whether
to bring charges.
The Atlanta Journal-Constitution
recently spoke
to anonymous members
of the grand jury,
who said the findings
were potentially explosive.
One juror said...
And another said...
That is quite the tease.
When I read that,
I was so shocked,
I stood up straight like
Ron DeSantis.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, if all that's true,
then I personally feel like
it might be better
to charge the guy
who fomented a violent coup
to overthrow American democracy
with coup stuff, first,
instead of the hush money stuff.
I'm not saying Trump shouldn't
face legal consequences
in that case, too.
I just think it might be better
for democracy
if we held Trump accountable
for the coup,
than if we charged him
for paying someone not
to talk about his little...
-Tacopina.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This
has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]